moments YouTuber Kai sanat is arrested
by NYPD for causing huge Union Square
riot with PS5 giveaway as writers are
filmed swarming on cars twerking on
lampposts and hurling bottles there's
one video we can't show and it's got a
guy who's bleeding profusely from the
arm apparently shot himself there's
reports that a cop had his throat cut in
some way and they took his gun from him
I don't know if that's true but then you
see this video this dude bleeding a
whole lot and you're like man
something's going on now keemstar says
that he spoke with Kai sinat's manager
he was not arrested as some were saying
the police are simply protecting him
from the mob and you can see here the
police are escorting him away we got a
bunch of other videos look at this one
here's a guy he's doing what looks like
some kind of Irish Dance on the top of
this black sedan well I mean it does
though but he's doing like the river
dance thing I don't know is that not
that's Michael Flatley Riverdance right
there yeah he was doing the legs back in
like filming a tick tock though but now
he's now he's jumping up and down and
they're just smashing this carp man
there's a bunch of crazy videos I don't
know what photos they got in uh on The
Daily Mail but like here's a dude and
his terrible form on that kick my friend
you know he should watch Joe Rogan do
that you see that video of Joe Rogan
doing that kick oh yeah it sounds like a
gunshot when he hits the the bag this
guy should watch more Joe Rogan uh look
at this some some guy's getting arrested
who's that so there were thousands of
people that showed up because I guess
they wanted a PlayStation and then once
once they're all there dude social order
breaks down that's it you know what I
was thinking
watching this video
it's like The Purge but in slow motion
everywhere because there was that woman
in Portland she got punched in the face
and now she's a republican you've got
Walgreens getting shut down you've got
Target stores locking every product
they're the Walgreens in Chicago where
they don't have products anymore have
you seen this well I've seen where
everything's locked up no no in
Walgreens you walk into the Chicago
Walgreens there's no products at all you
walk up to a terminal and you type in
what you want and someone will carry it
out for you if you pay for it like from
like a back armor ruining browsing
they're taking all the fun out of
shopping but you know what's funny is
Amazon tried doing that thing in Seattle
where you could walk in and take
whatever you wanted could you imagine
what it would be like if they put it in
San Francisco I mean maybe they have one
I don't know but you know Port where was
it was in Seattle yeah I was in Seattle
they put it in San Francisco Seattle's
bad enough but it's not as bad but now
they're going the other direction with
it where you walk into Walgreens there's
nothing but a counter in two terminals
you walk a terminal you type in what you
want to press enter and then after you
pay a person comes out with your bag and
says here you go well my favorite video
it went viral and I posted on my Twitter
too where it was a McDonald's in Kiev
and then a McDonald's in Los Angeles
California and the McDonald's in Los
Angeles the guys are like literally
beating up the cashiers stealing the
register and the one in Kiev in a war
zone it looked beautiful I mean it was
immaculate it couldn't have been any
cleaner so oh dude I've I was in um my
Dan when the when what effectively
turned into the Civil War erupted and
there's actually a crazy point to make
real quick when I went to uh 2013 and 14
when I was in Ukraine they were called
protests
those protests are now historically part
of the Civil War and now the Russian war
and potentially world war three yeah but
I'm in this place where they're burning
this building down like there's just
fire coming out and you walk into
McDonald's everything's fine you just
walk up to the counter and you're like
yeah I'll give him McChicken and you
know I think that's nice but McDonald's
is making everyone feel secure they're
providing the stable food yo same in
Egypt when I was at the Hilton you can
look out from the 26th floor and see
Tahir square and there's like lasers
everywhere people are screaming and
jumping up and down APC is riding around
right downstairs McDonald's is a guy
that's eating a cheeseburger watching
soccer it's The Equalizer everyone's
like we gotta protect McDonald's like
you don't riot in the middle of a church
in the U.S like the black lives matter
protests they'll just Loot and Destroy
Everything regardless of you know what
store they are
um so I guess they have no respect for
the sanctity of McDonald's what does
that say about us I guess well
McDonald's are better in Europe than
they are in America yeah that's true
yeah they're just and they give you
different stuff I think that's like
Chicago has a McDonald's where you can
go and order the international menu
really yeah that's where their
headquarters are yeah I think where
where is the first one is it it's not
Des Plaines is it the first McDonald's
was in California like San Bernardino
yeah but that was like that's deeply
controversial
first one I think was in Illinois or
something like that like after he ripped
the monster he took it over yeah dude
that was hit that movie Yo he's he was
Master masterfully done how he stole
that from him oh yeah it's crazy
he really created a real estate company
by exactly yeah so he owned the land
under him and then took them all that's
crazy and that's still their biggest uh
profit the real estate yeah oh yeah
anyway yeah we're talking about
McDonald's if you go to Iceland I think
you can get like mac and cheese jalapeno
bites at McDonald's
one of the best things like I've ever
seen was um you know their slogan I'm
loving it yeah it was uh Maddox you guys
remember Maddox the best page in the
universe he said I'm loving it as a
contraction of the phrase I am loving it
which is an anagram for ailing vomit I
was like that's actually pretty good I
wrote that I went to a McDonald's for
the first time in like five years in uh
when I was in Colorado Springs shooting
this music video and it was just a kiosk
there was nobody working anywhere so I
typed in what I wanted and I ordered
three double hamburgers I was just gonna
eat the meat and then they they served
they gave me the food and I left and I
checked and it was three single
hamburgers like you got one job
at this point the machine's doing it for
you how can you and I paid for double
double hamburgers but I was already gone
I didn't go back downstairs we were
talking about people destroying their
shoes were Americans being like but if
you go to Europe you gotta try the
McDonald's they've got interesting stuff
I do want to talk about this Times
Square riot because where the hell is a
National Guard Union Square Union Square
Downtown where's the National Guard how
long does it take to call someone on the
phone and be like yo get the get the big
guns in here to stop this before
buildings start getting blown up where
and this is like a is it right over or
are they still gone because this broke
pretty recently right yeah I don't know
if even like the mayor or Governor has
yeah anything what do you do when a
bunch of teenagers are just there the
riot started because they were there and
they knew no one could stop them
well New York's like Lawless right now I
mean even if you do get arrested because
of the bail reform you just get out of
jail so I mean I mean it's not a safe
place to be you guys heard about uh the
new based stick man right no do you
remember the Old Bay stick man yeah this
was the guy at the Battle for Berkeley
who had a stick and a mask and a shield
and when antifa started attacking people
he hit him with a stick now there's this
uh I think I think he's Indian or
Pakistani 7-Eleven worker in California
and they were getting robbed oh yeah and
then the guy filming is like you can't
do nothing about it just let it go and
then all of a sudden I what happens is
the bat like the guy robbing him pulls
out what looks like a knife of some sort
and the other dude he puts it away but
the guy grabs him and the other guy
starts beating him with a stick like bro
dude pulled out a weapon you know what I
mean and threatened them it's like what
are you supposed to do he was also
stealing he was feeling a giant garbage
cigarettes so like that's a lot of money
to lose for a store and at what point is
it like righteous to beat someone up
that's stealing from you I mean we in
Texas I think you have the legal right
to defend yourself with Force to defend
your property with Force I typically I'm
like man it shouldn't come down to like
that guy beat him merciles like yeah I
shouldn't say mercilessly because the
guy was stealing
the dude pulled a knife yeah you have a
weapon yeah the dude pulled the weapon
and threatened them with death now it's
like there's no longer a question of
morals it's like this this guy's
threatening to kill people like you
gotta you gotta protect yourself yeah
and I mean the guy's probably whacked
out on drugs I mean the guys you know if
you're making that decision he's
obviously well your adrenaline's going
too like it's a life or death situation
like yo look at this clip look at this
clip they're just jumping on random
people's cars what do you do they're
expressing themselves try that in a
small town yeah yeah I love that I love
that Meme because it's the stupidest
thing I've ever heard like try that in a
small town you mean when that Ahmed
Aubry guy yeah exactly oh my gosh right
those guys are now in prison for the
rest of their lives yeah yeah try it in
a small town and then the government
will come and arrest you Nancy Pelosi
suggested we get crew served weapons for
situations like this uh especially at
the capital yeah but the thing is if
this is like a flash mob that like there
was a Facebook post and a bunch of
people Facebook it's so I'm so Gen X
um and a bunch of people showed up and
then dispersed rapidly like how do you
defend against that because it takes
time for the Army to move like this is
obviously not dispersing rapidly yes
there's enough time for the this much
footage generated I feel like I mean
what is rapid I guess the cops what do
you do right so this Kai sinat guy is
like hey come to Instagram I'm gonna
give you a PlayStation and then a ride
happens did he do he didn't break the
law how it can't be a crime for you to
say I'm gonna be here and give a thing I
think they're saying an unlicensed
giveaway is something that I read that's
insane yeah to be like hello everyone
like imagine if you weren't famous and
you went and you called up like you went
on Facebook and said hey everyone I'm
going to be at Times Square I'm gonna
give you a PlayStation 10 people show up
nobody cares but because a million
people share it and thousands show up
now you're you've committed a crime
that's crazy to me sounds like the
Donald Trump thing right yeah that's
what I'm saying that's exactly what I
was going to say I mean there is kind of
some weight if you're that big of a
quote-unquote influencer and then you
influence a bunch of people to go do
something I mean I don't necessarily
think you should be liable but I mean he
has to take some responsibility a little
bit
is that alone but like he didn't tell
people to do this we did that thing
where I said hey everybody show up in DC
we're gonna skate and then like like a
couple hundred people showed up and we
skated nothing bad happened
that's not illegal no but then what if
people show up and do bad things why
would I be responsible for that simply
because I said hey I'm gonna be here
that's crazy to me is that why they
request permits because they don't want
to be out of control what I'm saying is
did he
organize
an event or did he just say I'm gonna be
in Times Square and I'm gonna give
someone a PlayStation like the idea that
it would be illegal for you to say
you're going to a place is insane to me
no matter who you are no matter how
famous you are yeah I mean I don't think
he told them to write either exactly
yeah yeah where's the anti-video game
people to be like see what happens when
you give out video game consoles I don't
understand like there's a whole advocacy
group here that would be saying like
this is how addicted people are to free
stuff and online like no one's
commenting on this I think part of that
is because they want to see what happens
right like that's why I feel like I
can't find a statement from um Eric
Adams mayor of New York because he's
waiting to see what happens before he
decides where he wants to put his
message that's kind of gross you know
what's going to happen is the left is
going to claim that the enforcement
against all these people was racist oh
yeah they're gonna say they're gonna
they're gonna try and spin it in any way
possible to be like oh you know they're
racist for you know how they did it
because when when Santa Con happens or
when football people you know go out and
it's just like St Patrick's Day they
just paid I think 13 million dollars to
a bunch of BLM writers that were
unfairly arrested did you not see that
in New York in New York yeah after the
fact yeah they just paid it out and some
of those people actually threw you know
Molotov cocktails at police cars the way
the way it works is you want to funnel
money from the government to extremists
the extremists who the government the
government goes oh gee oh no oh I guess
we should just settle well speaking of
actually sued New York City the city
council I was calling and zooming into
so many meetings they would see my name
and they just wouldn't let me speak so
we sued them in federal court and they
didn't want to deal with it and they
just we just settled for 15 000 bucks
yeah they paid me uh well they have 90
days and now we're on like day 45 but
yeah they already agreed I'll get the
check and whatever you know fifteen
thousand dollars fifty I have to split
with my attorney 60 40. but uh but I'm
your wife's boyfriend and my wife's
boyfriend if you love to bring up his
cut but uh my point is when you Sue I'm
actually suing Dallas County for a
similar thing they actually fight it New
York they're like ah the cost benefit
analysis it's just cheaper to pay these
so you're saying you can sue New York
City if the 15 000 I'll just pay you
well for your first amendment ride if
they violate your first amendment Riot
and don't let you speak well they didn't
prove they did like they did they you
didn't prove they did or didn't they
just said we don't want to bother with
it here's money yeah they didn't want to
to court and deal with it right so it
sounds like more than fifteen thousand
dollars exactly so it doesn't matter if
you're right or wrong well what I'm
saying is
where I'm suing they'll they'll actually
fight it New York they're just show over
you know inundated with lawsuits thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time